[Music]
like many American cities Albuquerque
has tried very hard to help
it's almost population get back on your
feet but one tactic in particular seems
to be working
it involved this guy will Cole he drives
around in a van and approaches
panhandlers with an offer interested I'm
working today all right come on hop in
let's go get it done
thank you guys
[Music]
our story is about a citizen decided to
tackle a chronic problem with a simple
idea that first brand of life inside the
mayor's brain hello I'm Richard Berry
and I'm the mayor of Albuquerque New
Mexico for so many years of so many
decades with homelessness panhandling
he's always been about buying somebody a
bus ticket to the next city I just
wanted to stop doing that
[Music]
the mayor called with a plan to give
jobs to panhandler and I knew just a
person to lead the charge she was
thinking of will : who at the time was a
security guard at the shelter in a van
paid for by the city will is the
homeless shelter at 7:30 a.m. we're at
around the city we locate panel is a
different worse site we approach them
and ask them if they're willing to work
and if they are we take them to our work
site and we get the jobs on the roof
factory thank you sir
morning guys
all right either litter sweep or pulling
weeds
it's a city beautification program
that's what it's all about my name is
Martita meeteth I've been homeless for
almost three years I've been working
with will for around four months and you
helped me on a lot guys they make
realize what I had before we offer them
a six hour shift of work and we pay them
in cash a nine dollars an hour all right
thank you for the day and here you go on
thank you much if I were an employer I
would hire a whole bunch of our clients
that we pick up I think a lot of time
the situation there and they don't get a
chance and I'm glad that we're able to
give them that chance and get them
started in just over a year we'll has
employed hundreds of people and they've
cleaned up 400 city blocks and removed
over a hundred and twenty thousand
pounds of litter and the idea has spread
to six other cities including Chicago
and Denver most importantly dozens of
people like Mike Whitaker here have
found permanent jobs and housing after
working with will after I started
working on the better way program I got
this job doing 25 hours a week and have
an apartment of my own I showed me I
could show up for work every day and do
the job and be sober I got used to being
around people again having conversation
thank you will and to bring this story
sweet circle the mayor just came up with
another idea well as this year's Good
Samaritan idolatress it just shows you
how a little ripple can turn into a big
wave and get a lot of things going for
people you start small but it gets
triggered
you
[Music]